the creeks of the Niger River Delta are
its lifeline they provide food work and
even a place to wash but they're full of
oil before you could not be able to see
the other side because of the mangrove
vegetation it covered the whole of this
area by the pollutions of 2008 and 2009
destroy the hopeless
this is boto a small community in an
area of southern Nigeria called
agony land almost everyone here lived
off that land fishing or farming in 2008
two oil spills from shell pipelines
devastated the environment and people's
livelihoods but I could not be able to
put food on the table Murdock would not
be able to put food on the table their
children could not go to school they
wouldn't have fish to eat and so the
community become more less than a
refugee community spills are common in
the Delta around 240 thousand barrels of
oil leak out into the creeks every year
technically shell stop producing oil and
gas in Oconee land in the 90s but it's
pipelines still pump it through the
region this former refinery is only a
few miles from boto it was shut down in
1993 after violent protests against the
oil industry the jungle has started to
reclaim the land but even after 20 years
oil still leaks out into the ground it's
going to take about 13 years for the
creek to be restore so within that
period she'll have me billions of pounds
from here they came here in 1958 and
this is where they have lived for more
than 40 sonken good years in 2012 the
Boro community took shelter Court in
London and after a three-year legal
battle they won and they came out that
share should be booed of people 55
million
oh there was jubilation Saul over I
myself John more than any other person
I jumped more than another person
because the first place our heart in
Africa the shell our media liability it
was a landmark victory and a chance to
revitalize the community the money was
supposed to be divided into two parts
one for individual claims and one for
community development instead the 15,000
residents decided to share all the money
equally each got around 900,000 IRA
which is about four thousand five
hundred dollars it doesn't sound like a
lot but here 50% of the population live
on only $1 a day and what did they do
with the money
most of them build houses it was a
madhouse here before after receiving
their compensation they were able to put
up this structure and because the money
was not enough they would not be able to
roof it again the lucky ones managed to
finish their new houses but many only
have a shell of a home and are still
living in mud huts still the residents
of boto say they had a good reason to
share the money 99% of this community
are in favor of chair in Grozny because
if we want to use it for contract our
leaders are so corrupt and we don't
trust them they will they will
manipulate that money and they will not
do a good clean job and it's not just
boto that's been affected as you can see
now yeah is the waterfront going
community what are firms they are all
impact a sight you observe the area you
see the kicks peels the neighboring
community of going is also suing shell
over the same oil spills this bone had
been here in 1979 fit in my family and
and they extended families my father
accumulated over a hundred workers but
first son giving
deep-sea fishing bakery school poor tree
and the transpose
Eric says he's learned from bodas
experience any payments from shell will
be used differently in go e so if when
it comes back I have to reinvest in
those areas to see that they are
functional and make it in job
opportunity for people the truth is that
no amount of reinvestment will really
change things here until the environment
is restored as part of the settlement
shell is meant to be in cleaning the
creeks by October 2016 but there are
fears that even if she'll eventually
stumps up the cash it will never make it
to boto if that money for the cleanup is
given to one agency your way here the
monies in America tomorrow below may
have won millions but money alone isn't
going to solve the problems here